So for me,
as an entrepreneur, what are the type of
design types that I need to care about?
>> So
my specialty is interaction design,
so as you've probably guessed from
me saying task, task, task over and
over again for the last few minutes,
that's where I bias towards.
So kind of we focus on trying to
understand users and behaviors.
Think about the types of things
that they want to do, and
how to best fulfill them.
Now that's just one of
the specializations.
There's many.
Other very common ones
are visual design.
They focus on everything
that the user sees while they're
engaging with your experience.
>> Is there like, colors,
and stuff like that, or?
>> Colors is one, but it's also
things like layout, like scale,
any iconography that's there,
everything from fonts and
upward, anything that becomes
a pixel in that piece of software.
>> Right.
>> Visual design
tries to concentrate on that.
And there's thousands of small
decisions that go into that,
that is their specialization.
Then there's also things
like motion design.
This is a newer focus for
design in many cases.
And they're concerned with how
anything animates, big or small.
To give the user a sense that
their feedback is being heard, and
that the system's responding to it.
And just to kind of bring
the product to life a little bit.
They make it feel like it's something
they're really kind of engaging in
this push and pull way.
>> You can also stress things
with animation, right?
>> Absolutely.
Animation is a great way to
tell the user where their
attention should be
focused at any given time.
And then there's other specializations.
There's things like Industrial design,
the design of physical objects.
>> Right.
>> There's sound design, there's brand,
or print design, and so
on and so on and so on.
Anything that you're doing
on this product that has
some decision that needs to be made,
there's probably
a whole discipline of design that
can help you make that decision.
>> So what you're basically telling me
is that I need to hire eight people?
>> Yes.
Wait, no, no.
You can get by with fewer.
>> Okay.
>> So I know most small teams just don't
have that capacity to hire
out all the specializations.
So the good news is that, in my
experience, most designers are hybrids.
They might identify as being one of
those specializations, but they often
have familiarity to varying degrees
with the other fields of the discipline.
So what's important to
keep in mind when you hire
is kind of have a sense of what
your expectations are going to be.
What are you going to need
out of this designer?
Do you need interaction and visual?
Do they need to work on your brand for
you?
And make sure that the capabilities
are in the people that you hire.
Or, make sure that they are comfortable
directing the work of contractors who
might be able to kind of augment
the capabilities that they lack.
>> How do they know if they're any good?
>> [LAUGH] Wow, that's a good question.
I think the best way to judge
a designer is from their work.
So you should certainly ask for
work samples.
You should look for the portfolio.
You should find out what kind of
things get them excited about design.
>> Right.
>> Are they very focused on the user and
on simplicity?
Are they a designer who can come in and
give more pizzazz, a little sex appeal,
a little gloss to the product?
There's appeal to having all those
types of people involved with the work.